expression and protein interaction
approach to identify awesome machines
i'm an omnics logic fellow and a data
science intern at columbia university
firstly there is a high prevalence of
autism as 1 in 44 children are afflicted
by the disorder the clinical diagnosis
of autism has been limited by the lack
of conclusive biomarkers and the high
genetic and clinical heterogeneity in
regards to autism's etiology and
homework symptoms
for chd7 a high confidence gene and slit
one one of the candy genes i identify in
this study you can see that these genes
share high expression levels and similar
expression profiling however sdf4 are
not associated gene has little to no
significant expression hello my name is
nambira and i have done a project on
developing novel drug candidates for mdd
mmd and hypertension and i am part a
high schooler at crystal springs uplink
school so the second messenger cgmp is
extremely important target for disorders
such as heart failure atherosclerosis
and cardiac hydrotrophy disorders
affecting millions
the sgc protein is a site that converts
gtp to cgmp a small molecule control
vasodilation currently very few dino
therapeutics target the sgc cgmp pathway
due to many unknowns about the protein
structure and qualities it has a role in
rare diseases like mmd and it is
extremely important to target
cgmt to find treatments cjnp can not
only treat cardiovascular disorders
causing up to 31 percent of that's
worldwide but also have a role in cancer
regulation major depressive disorder and
more
for the genetic analysis rnf213 gene
coexpression
hcl z2 has a spearmint correlation of
0.769 it is a co-actuator for the
peroxisome proliferated activated
receptor alpha and oas3 regulates the
expression of chemokines and interferon
responsive genes similarly for the gene
gua 1b1 map9 has a spearmint correlation
at 0.746 and is required for spindle
function
so after the genetic analysis and
structural analysis are done
binding affinities are collected through
docking molecular docking so the five
ligands with the top most are mustang
binding values
are have their pharmacokinetic
properties analyzed
and their chemical moieties were
analyzing primal to reinforce if they
were good candidates
by gathering this important structural
information drug candidates are proposed
after conducting a virtual scanning
thousands of ligands drug candidates
namely
c15h24 and
c9h11no and c16h20 and 404
were identified the drug targets
identified can move on to lab testing on
animal models to be developed further
into medication as their lack of fda
approved treatments finally a
combination of invasive treatment and
medication can be used to reduce the
chance of stroke or high blood pressure
a soluble guanola cyclist contributes to
a variety of conditions from
hypertension and mmd to even cancer for
the research and drugs targeting sgc
would be imperative
so here are my references and thank you
so much
so um hi everyone i am ajah i am
currently an undergraduate student in
the field of biomedical sciences and
research today i will be presenting my
research on gene expression methanol
this is of colorectal cancer tumor cells
that release genes in association with
tumor geneticists yeah to do the
introduction more than 12 million people
are every day diagnosed with colorectal
cancer and 600 000 people die from it
it's very deadly disease however the
pathogenesis of colorectal cancer is
still not known
this work identifies 13 gene signatures
representing force trc tumor scene
signatures and 10 other glandular tumor
gene signatures that are colonic by
origin gene set enrichment analysis
approach has been used to define
positive and negative crc gene panels
from gse identified leading l genes the
leading edge genes were identified and
later used to verify enrichment and
significant edge gene membership of crc
panels in different types of glandular
tumors in origin
gica-based approaches here used to
analyze the diseases and mrna expression
data of tumor and normal colorectal
cancer tissues derived from human
colonic biopsy samples by defining and
comparing gene expression signatures
in order to examine the gene expression
changes associated with tumor formation
in crc differential gene expression
analysis was carried on using the wedge
to wedge t test to sample analysis the t
test score of clean and normalized value
was used in order to define the gene
panels
the t-test course later defined 13 gene
signatures which were of statistical
significance the signatures are formed
from the gene list ranked from high to
low differential gene expression between
tumor versus normal samples the
signatures derived from the same data
set use the same control samples okay so
however our work that identifies certain
kinds of solute carrier family genes
could be useful and it needs to be
proved by wetlab research or western
blot techniques or qt pcr techniques in
order to validate that these genes are
involved in colorectal cancer disease
tumor genesis which could assess that
the gse based approach that we use is
more useful and identifying certain
kinds of genes which normal environment
tools like fail or are not that uh
efficient to derive so thank you so much
so i have really enjoyed looking at all
of the presentations i've also really
enjoyed listening to everybody today
i must say i'm quite impressed at the
caliber of the presentations but also of
the work
and it's really great to see some early
you know early career researchers really
tackling some real world problems
and that's been very exciting um all of
the talks today did some some hectic
analyses and i think you should all
patch yourselves on the back
and i think you should also be very very
proud of your progress um in such a
short span of time it's been truly
impressive and i'm really really
enjoying it um and i hope to to be here
for a lot more of today's um
of today's session so that i can hear
some more from from everybody else but
it's been really really wonderful and
i've really been liking the posters as
well the posters are fantastic so just
well done guys it's
really good